[Music]
at 54 years old Mikhail Gorbachev became
the youngest leader of the Soviet Union
and he was to be the last
few would doubt that he changed the
course of 20th century history although
he's revered and respected more in the
west than in modern Russia
one of his biggest achievements was
signing a disarmament treaty with U.S
president Ronald Reagan that took out a
whole class of nuclear weapons it earned
him a Nobel Peace Prize
Joe Biden cited this achievement in his
tribute describing Gorbachev as a man of
remarkable vision
he said the result was a safer world and
greater freedom for millions of people
Vladimir Putin said Gorbachev had a huge
impact on the course of world history he
deeply understood reforms were necessary
and strove to offer Solutions
Antonio Gutierrez the U.N Secretary
General said the world has lost a
towering Global leader committed
multilateralists and tireless advocate
for peace the EU commission president
Ursula vonder Lyons said Gorbachev
played a crucial role to end the Cold
War and bring down the Iron Curtain it
opened the way for a free Europe many
Russians see him as the man who stood by
as the Soviet Union disintegrated his
legacy is that he allowed for the
peaceful collapse
of the Soviet Union he did not use
massive Force to keep Eastern Europe uh
in the Empire and for that he deserves
credit but it is not that this was
someone who came in trying to undermine
the system he tried to reform it
Gorbachev used perestroika all
restructuring to reform a stagnant's
economy that had seen people short of
food and consumer goods
and he used glasnost openness and
freedom of speech that led to parts of
the Eastern Bloc rising up against
communism
it was the beginning of the end of the
Cold War one state after the other broke
away Angela Merkel former German
Chancellor spoke in her tribute of the
fear in East Germany with expectation
the tanks would roll in but quite the
contrary wasn't long before the Berlin
Wall came down
[Applause]
yet now 30 years on with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine comes a danger of
further East-West conflict
Russia and its president are digging new
trenches in Europe and have started a
horrible war in Ukraine it's now we
think of Mikhail Gorbachev and realize
what he did for our country and all of
Europe
Gorbachev held as a man of Peace has
died at a time when his country is
heavily engaged in war Andrew Simmons Al
Jazeera